hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so
in this video i would like to discuss
with you something that
i'm seeing a lot on my discord that i'm
seeing a lot as well in
other youtubers analysis it's the
parabolic
arc pattern that we're having on amc so
i want to tell you everything that i
found
about this pattern and everything that
this is telling us
so let's get into it
so what is the parabolic art pattern
good question i tried to find some
information so basically just for those
who
are watching my videos for the first
time i used to be working as a trader
for the past
six years i just quit my job one month
ago and i'm using technical analysis
every day i used to
use technologies every day to make my
trends and i've never heard of this
parabolic arc
pattern but fair enough you know you
have different trading
techniques so this is one of them so i
did my research guys and i found some
information like for example here
maybe this one is more relevant so
basically you have here
a parabolic curve has then some
retracements
and it's funny that to see that actually
those
retracements you know usually they said
so it's a bearish pattern that says that
once
i don't exactly understand which level
is broken you're gonna find some support
level
between the 62 and 79 guys what's that
see it's not 62 it's 61.8 you know that
and it nets
it's not 79 it's 78.6 yes those are just
the fib retracement levels all right so
this is
fibonacci applied to a strong move up
and what
is this guys you know base 1 base two
base three base four so this is an
example with bitcoin
and guys this is just edit wave theory
but with
less details less information you know
all the waves
have the same length that's not true you
guys know that some of them are extended
so basically for me i didn't have any
very interesting information
when i did my research but i'm still
gonna try to apply the
method and see what this is telling us
so for the first time guys
i'm gonna use my chart not with
logarithmic scale but with a regular
scale all right
i don't like to do this because the
stocks they're not moving you know
in absolute value they're moving in a
percentage the groove
has always been in percentage guys so it
doesn't make sense to me to look a chart
like this
but just for the sake of trying
to do things like i saw let's do it like
this
so here is the parable that's what they
say fair enough but this is one two
three four five you know that guys
i can't help but labeling it guys all
right
so one two okay so this is a one two
three four five
this is a one two three we're having
here four and we are waiting for the
fifth you guys
know that so here if i measure the
retracement level of this move what do i
find
guys between the 61.8 and 78.6 once
again guys
this is thieves all right they call it
parabolic what goes up blah blah blah so
they basically say that it's a
so psychology behind pattern but the
parabolic patterns consist of both panic
buying and panic sending scenarios
probably cap moves vertically as pain by
any extent in an absence of sellers on
some
unfounded expectations blah blah blah so
they basically think that's too bearish
pattern guys alright so this is what i
found here place a protective stop a few
ticks above the high so this is to take
a short position interesting but this is
not telling us
when the breakout is going to happen
this is not telling us what are the
targets for the
fifth wave so to me this complementary
information was
actually not that complementary it was
already included it's basically
a basic use of fibs and elliott wave
theory combined this is basically what
i'm doing guys in all of my videos
so here let me do it again with you so
we have this one two three four five
so yeah we're having some support level
at between 30 33
and 22 so once again guys this is not
very precise let me zoom in a little bit
so you guys know that for those who are
following me on discord i gave you
many tips here yesterday during the
trading session i was actually in the 15
minutes time frame
so i'm gonna come back to the daily um
maybe trading
but just very quickly let me give you my
targets once again guys because the
parabolic arc pattern doesn't tell you
what is triggering the next move up i'm
giving you this this is at
the 38 40 area guys and i've explained
that many times i will explain this here
too again
this is when the fifth wave is going to
be triggered all right this is what we
are
waiting for and the targets guys i gave
you this many times but let's do it
again
you measure the wave and you apply to
the bottom of the force so not sure
where it's gonna be guys
maybe somewhere somewhere here and yes
we're going to 135
if it's the 1.618 feed extensions that
is happening and once again guys where
do i get this information from you know
i don't
just say that randomly you tap edit wave
theory thrust and pressure pdf ram you
click on this link
okay and you look for fibonacci and
we're going to find the fibs
extension that eliot predicted guys 50
years ago all right
this is a solid theory this is a theory
where you have support levels
resistance levels that you have some
forecast about
how long is going to be the next wave
depending on which wave was extended
before
here we go guys some of you might have
seen that
already guys this is what i'm using and
we are here in this situation for me
right fifth wave extension so basically
we
are going to have a fifth wave which
lengths
is 1.618 compared to one two three so
this is what
i'm doing here guys all right so this is
a solid theory
if you want to know more about the
theory just click on the link in the
description of my video i go through the
whole book that i've read many times yes
this is solid information
that i'm giving you here and it's
basically coming to the same
answer that we're going to 100 135 but
here i'm having some levels that help me
to identify whenever
it's time to go in the trade or whenever
it's time to wait all right and right
now i can tell you it's time to wait we
need to break fully
to be sure now for those who are
interested i will go
on a 15 minute time frame and i will i
will go quickly with you guys
through my different scenarios scenarios
that i post every day guy on my discord
go there it's still for free
i'm basically giving you some training
guidelines i'm helping you guys to find
the nice buying opportunities during the
day
and yesterday let me sum up a bit the
situation so those are my three
scenarios guys so i was sending you in
my discord
so that here we had the breakout at 33
guys and i told you
wait for it you know some of you were
ready for more
rushing like yeah i want to buy i want
to buy i was like wait wait wait guys
we're going to have 90
chance that there is a retest at 33 in
the coming hour and this is exactly what
happened here guys we had this free test
and then i told you the next resistance
level would be 35 we had some reaction
here at 35
and then again again and again all right
so i kind of predicted
the whole price action during yesterday
because guys i'm used to that you know
it's something i've been watching charts
guys for the past
even 10 15 years yes every day trying to
you know scalp it
day trade it swim trade it so i
basically kind of
know which techniques are gonna work
depending on the
uh recent transaction that i'm having
and i'm now you know focused on amc
price action for quite a while so i'm
just you know
kind of predicting things pretty well
and i
am pretty convinced that i'm going to
keep giving you guys some
very precious information here and so
here once again to sum up the situation
we have three
scenarios this one is my less likely
scenario
to keep in mind guys we might go to 24
still as long as we are
below 40 which is this trend line guys
this is the trend line that here is
telling me guys that we are still in the
bearish development and as long as we
are below this trend line guys we are
at risk so there are two scenarios
orange and red
that lead to 24 for me and there is one
scenario which i give 35
chance so roughly one third that is
going to go higher so you're going to
tell me you basically don't know what
will happen
yes i don't know what will happen but i
have some levels that
once they are broken it gives me
information that i can use to enter a
trade using a retest
or to secure some profits for example if
i buy at 33
then i can sell a bit of my shares at
40. i know you guys don't like to start
i'm just giving you some day trading
tips here and yeah those are my three
scenarios guys so
roughly they have all the same
probability and here what is going to
tell us once again that we are starting
this this wave is this
so here i would stay put if you don't
want to a day trade you just stay put
you wait for the breakout
here and then you buy the retest and
then you're gonna be set up for this
strong move up guys that are really very
strong is gonna come
100 maybe 150
depending how high we managed to go and
once again the parabolic arc
is not giving you guys any targets i'm
giving you targets
we might take 250 percent after
this breakout occurred this is my view
and i'm just using fibs and elliot that
is a solid
theory so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything
new so stay close to show guys